قال رئيس تركيا مرارًا وتكرارًا
إنه لن يدعم محاولة السويد وفنلندا
للانضمام إلى الناتو
مدعيا أنهما يؤويان
إرهابيين ، وهو ما غير موقفه
جيدًا ، وأعتقد بالتأكيد أن الولايات المتحدة لعبت
دورًا في ذلك كما سمعتم من كيفن
هناك دفع الرئيس التركي رجب
جو إلى  مهاجم واحد في هذا أه
سابقًا بدا كما لو أن تركيا لم تكن
في عجلة من أمرها للتوصل إلى صفقة ، لكن من الواضح أن
هذا مكسب كبير دبلوماسيًا ليس
فقط لتركيا ولكن أيضًا للسويد
وفنلندا الآن ، حيث تم السماح لهما بالدخول إلى
الناتو ولكن على وجه الخصوص  انتصار
لحلف الناتو وكان الأمين العام لحلف الناتو هو
الذي أعلن عن هذه
الاتفاقية واستمع لما
قاله ويسعدني أن أعلن أن لدينا الآن
اتفاقًا يمهد الطريق لفنلندا
والسويد
للانضمام إلى الناتو
تركيا
فنلندا والسويد
وقعت على مذكرة تعالج
مخاوف تركيا
بما في ذلك حول صادرات الأسلحة
ومكافحة الإرهاب
الآن بشكل أساسي
ما وعدت به فنلندا والسويد  لمعالجة
المخاوف الأمنية لتركيا لا سيما أنها
تتعامل مع مجموعات الاستقلال الكردية
التي تعتبرها تركيا جماعات إرهابية ،
على سبيل المثال ، اتفقت السويد وفنلندا
على أنها لن تدعم
وحدات حماية الشعب الكردي أو وحدات حماية الشعب
وأنهم سيعترفون
بحزب العمال الكردي.  حزب سياسي
كمنظمة إرهابية موصوفة
، وهذا يجعل السويد
وفنلندا تتماشى حقًا مع الطريقة التي ترى بها تركيا
هذه الجماعات وكذلك الولايات المتحدة في الاتحاد الأوروبي
التي ترى أن هذه الأخت تعتبر حزب العمال الكردستاني
جماعة إرهابية أيضًا ،
لذا فهذه ليست سوى بعض من
التيارات الأمنية من بين جميع القضايا
أيضًا أنه لن يكون هناك
حظر أسلحة بين الدولة
وسيتم تشكيل إطار لجمع المعلومات الاستخباراتية ،
لذلك هناك الكثير مما يجري هناك
ويجب أن أشير إلى أن اللغة الدبلوماسية
غامضة بما يكفي  السماح
بتفسيرات مختلفة من قبل
كل بلد